[Musique]
salut maronie alors quel est le sujet du
jour salut mon coeur aujourd'hui nous
allons découvrir comme dispositif
département l'aide ménager à légal ça
tombe bien j'en aurai bien besoin pour
ma case
parce que l'aide ménager à s'adresse aux
personnes âgées de 60 ans et plus et aux
personnes en situation d'handicap et tu
verras ce n'est pas que le ménage si
vous aussi
à légal rester avec moi
[Musique]
permet aux personnes en situation
handicapées aux personnes âgées de plus
de 60 ans de bénéficier des aides de
services nécessaires à l'accomplissement
des activités liées à certains travaux
ménagers ce dispositifs quotidienne en
plus d'apporter une présence
[Musique]
bonjour Eliane bonjour Monique il y a
actuellement l'aide ménagère du
département en quoi ça y est en tout
monsieur ça nous permet de discuter un
petit peu avec la personne qui vient en
s'entend bien je suis fier de mon
nettoyage donc c'est très important qui
est dans beaucoup de quotidien c'est
tout c'est tout monsieur maintenant on a
on a quelqu'un pour faire c'est vraiment
vraiment un très très belle chose qu'ils
ont fait pour combien de fois par
semaine l'aide de ménager à le dire
c'est une fois par semaine de 7 heures à
9h merci beaucoup Eliane merci beaucoup
le département est chargé de délivrer
l'aide ménagère légale cette aide permet
de financer l'intervention d'un
prestataire le service à domicile pour
l'accomplissement de certains travaux
ménagers
[Musique]
légal elle a été créée pour favoriser le
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
de 60 ans et plus qui ne bénéficient pas
de la PA qui ne rentre pas dans les
critères de la PA et les personnes
porteuses d'un handicap tout en sachant
que l'aide ménagère est cumulable avec
la PCH et du Maine car la PCH du Maine
ne frotte pas la prestation du ménage et
de la préparation des repas en quoi
consiste cette aide alors cette aide
consiste comme son nom l'indique à aider
les personnes à faire leur ménage mais
aussi à préparer leur repas et pourquoi
pas et les accompagner pour faire les
courses quelles sont les démarches à
suivre pour pouvoir en bénéficier alors
pour en bénéficier je conseille aux
demandeurs de se rendre dans leur CCAS
c'est un partenaire précieux parce qu'il
va les aider à constituer leur dossiers
vérifier qu'il est bien complet le CCAS
va ensuite transmettre cette demande au
service de l'aide sociale aux adultes du
département c'est un service qui va
vérifier que les critères sont bien
remplis
ce service va transmettre la demande aux
équipes des actions de santé et nous
allons prendre rendez-vous avec les
personnes âgées ou les personnes
porteuses d'un handicap pour venir chez
elle évaluer leurs besoins est-ce que
les bénéficiaires ont-ils une
participation à payer alors oui
actuellement la participation horaires
et d'un euro 82 donc il touche pas les
ritages il faut rassurer les personnes
et c'est vrai qu'elle nous est souvent
demandé les gens des fois même hésitent
à faire cette demande à cause de ça non
le à la réunion il a été décidé que il
n'y ait pas de recours sur succession
merci Laurent merci Maroni
grâce à l'aide ménagère le quotidien de
nos rameau ne des personnes handicapées
devient plus facile la visite de ces
prestataires permet de mettre en ordre
le logement qu'elle lui soit attachés
mais aussi de rompre l'isolement
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur les ménagères
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affichent sur votre
écran le département de génération c'est
fini si vous souhaitez on va voir cet
épisode ainsi que les épisodes
précédents rendez-vous sur le site et
nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je vous
retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous partons à la
rencontre de Louane une jeune femme qui
a bénéficié de la bourse départementale
une aide financière du département qui
s'adresse aux jeunes Réunionnais pour
leur favoriser l'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur
[Musique]